[Música]
no céu da ilha
se eu tô b
a decoração muito aquém a chave da
cidade que sempre foi mal apagado na
verdade ficou resolvida a gente não
passou de um padre
meu coração ainda quem muita saudade e
se for mal apagado na verdade e como
resolvido a gente não passou de fase
o passado viró presente
costa quer se debater los de frente no
jogo do coração
é o destino brincando com a gente é que
saudade de você ter salvado de você
[Música]
ae não troca mais a nossa luta mas é
porque o nossa sua
aqui eu tenho que a gente esquece
até pensei que
mas o seu rosto seu território
seu corpo mundo meu
a sonda quem é saudade e se for mal
apagado na verdade ficou resolvida gente
não passou de fase
meu coração ainda que nossa saudade que
sinto formal à faca na verdade como
resolvida a gente não gostou do varzim o
passado
a gente conta kesk que bateu de frente
no show do coração é o destino cantando
com a gente
a salada que você é
o nó
ele
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]